You guys, if you need a new mattress,
the TikTok Shop is the place to go.
There less than $200,
and I'm telling you,
this is the best sleep I've had of my adult life.
The mattress is a combination of pocketed springs
and high density gel memory foam.
So you get the best of both worlds with the sturdiness of springs,
but the firmness of the memory foam.
It's also a cooling memory foam,
so it kind of helps you stay cool as you sleep.
There was no smell in unboxing this mattress,
and it does. It comes vacuum seal,
so you just kind of undo it.
These are the coil springs that are on the bottom,
and then the top is has the gel memory foam.
This is the 14 inch.
I highly recommended.
It's linked here in the TikTok shop.
It's amazing. Go get one.